from the beginning today's guest is
jedidiah beale a former conservative
co-host
of uh the view which is a tough place to
be and to be conservative she's been all
over fox author uh new website coming up
billa.locals.com
and she has a tendency of ruffling
feathers she likes to push the envelope
so tell us is that genetics is that you
have you always been this way well i'm
italian so you know that comes with the
turf but you know i think pushing the
envelope today means that you're just
being honest with people so i don't you
know i don't tell a line for politicians
i don't tell a line for a political
party i really tell you what i think i
am a conservative and i think i'm
getting increasingly conservative as the
days pass to be perfectly honest um
libertarian conservative i hate these
labels it's like they don't mean
anything i'd rather just tell you what i
think
but i'm not someone who's gonna get a
hundred percent behind a politician and
decide whoever this politician is i'm
gonna support everything they say
because i you know bow down to them and
i don't play that game so i think what
you get is honesty and that makes people
mad sometimes and that's perfectly fine
with me i'd rather give them the truth
and have them be mad than lie to them
and have them love me so yeah what's
crazy is that that's the ideal person to
be on the view right somebody like you
they like
uh the other day i saw the article the
the fact that they're having a hard time
finding somebody to
you know replace a conservative co-host
but this person
the the demos of this person has to be
somebody that doesn't like trump
believes january 6 was an insurrection
they have to be pro-vaxxed they have to
be somebody not provex they have to be
somebody that's vaccinated they have to
be somebody that is supporting bill it's
like so many different things to say
this is what we're looking for why don't
you just go out there and say you're
looking for a fifth democrat to be there
right yeah well what they're actually
looking for in in my opinion is a
conservative and i have my little
quotation marks
that fits a liberal's definition of what
an acceptable conservative is so they
want to be able to say well we want
someone who is going to go out there and
we can say we have a conservative on the
panel we can use that word but they're
going to agree with us most of the time
and when they disagree they're going to
do it quietly they're not going to
ruffle feathers and we're still going to
get to be right i believe that's called
a unicorn i don't know if those people
even exist yeah and you know i was i was
talking to them um again i you know had
worked there for
about a year and a half a full year of
contract and about a half a year of
testing before that and i was supposed
to go on this year
to co-host again as you know megan left
the show supposed to go in october
and then um
i was all set to go they came to my
house they accepted my medical exemption
for the vaccine they had someone come to
my house they covet tested me i tested
negative i got a call the next day oh
the policy has changed you have to be
vaccinated i said well i'm i can't do it
i'm sorry like i'm not going to do it i
had coveted already i have documented
immunity going on 20 you know 19 months
at the time now it's more than that
and i have an exemption from my doctor
who's saying this is not right for me
so they said you know what let's see
what happens in november i was supposed
to go back and and do the book and
november rolled around and they said
we're sorry we can't have you so the
executive producer over there who's
who's very nice who i like brian he's a
generally good guy as far as i know he's
been nice to me said we're going to take
it remote
so i did a full pre-interview with them
full pre-interview where i talked about
the mandates i talked about how i felt
about it they wanted me to have that
conversation
they grilled me prep you did they say
we're gonna ask you yes okay so you knew
that was gonna be a hundred percent
because she said let's get the elephant
out you know yes they said no they said
where do you stand they knew where i
stood because i had been very vocal
about not only the fact that i wasn't
backs all over twitter was me saying
these mandates are not scientific you
cannot justify them here's why so they
knew where i stood we did a full
pre-interview i get on the show i opened
my mouth for two seconds and they say oh
that's misinformation which it wasn't
what i actually said on air was actually
fact which we now know because we're
seeing it unfold in the country exactly
what i said which was and and frankly to
cite the cdc we can get into what i said
but
i think my point is you know they want
and this happens all the time in liberal
media they hire a conservative supposed
conservative and then you listen and
you're like that's not a conservative
that's a liberal or that's someone who's
just gonna be what you want them to be
that's not me in case you haven't
noticed in the brief amount of time i'm
here i'm not malleable like that so um
but i don't think that's good tv though
i i don't think it's good tv to not be
you or to not be megan like i thought
both of you were a good fit i thought it
was you know uh
that that that you know going back and
forth is what makes good tv and that's
what makes the audience to sit there and
say i agree with her i don't agree with
her i agree with what she has to say
she's wrong so uh i don't know if it's
good tv i'm trying to see what the
strategy really is
and i wonder if it helps with viewership
long term because if it does then you
got to do what the viewership's working
and are there only five women on the
show is that the number yes and why
wouldn't they you know because it's four
liberals one why wouldn't it be three
and two you ever thought about that like
why wouldn't it be you and megan like
the supreme court
yeah what's the story with that what it
should really be
is five women who see things differently
as much as possible so you could have a
moderate republican on there you could
then have a real conservative
conservative have a trump supporter on
have they anticipated
so that you know people who have
different ways of life you know have
someone on there who has a bunch of kids
someone on there who's single and
doesn't want to get married you know i
think if it's about the view
you know it's called the view maybe it
is the view as in one you know but if if
you're really looking to get
perspectives out there of
different people around the country then
that's not what's happening you know and
and it is
listen i don't know i don't know if some
of it has to do with pleasing
advertisers i had many conversations
throughout this uh past year because i
wasn't going to get the vaccine i heard
from a lot of liberal um liberals in
production that were saying you know
you could make the argument about the
mandate but if you were vaccinated it
would be easier because then you're like
in the club
and i said well what club is it exactly
i mean like why and honestly there's a
bunch of people around the country who
opted not to get it for medical reasons
for other reasons so why is that
viewpoint not valid to have that person
represented especially because we know
the vaccine doesn't prevent you from
getting or spreading the disease so it's
completely absurd
that
you're what you're saying is a view that
that's what cdc is saying that's not
what you're saying cdc even came out and
said even the vaccine even if you have
it so it's not like your opinion or
something well that's what was labeled
misinformation though i mean i was shut
down on national television for just
simply saying the cdc has said that if
you're vaccinated you can also get and
spread covid i mean you don't have to be
paying attention to the cdc to know that
just look around yeah everyone i know
right now who has coveted is vaxxed
that's not to say that unvaccinated
people didn't get covered all through
last year of course they did but that
shouldn't be you know
it's active discrimination against
people you know and why are you not
honoring medical exemptions and why are
you not accepting the reality that
everyone has an individual medical
history with a past with certain you
know reactions they've had to x y and z
so you know these are political talking
points that are being but the argument
to that to your point is that
if you are vaxxed and you do get coveted
which i agree with you
you were down in miami i was down to
miami for art basel everyone i know got
copied literally everybody like boom
covet bomb backs non-vax whatever
correct but the argument to that would
be
if you are vexed it'll be less severe
it'll keep you out of the hospital or
keep the hospital from going over
capacity what are your thoughts on that
so that doesn't justify a mandate though
because if you're going to do that
talk to me about obesity talk to me
about smokers talk to me about people
who drink too much talk to me about
people who don't exercise there are a
whole bunch of lifestyle reasons that
cause people to go into the hospital and
burden the hospital system i'm you know
i'm a healthy person i exercise a lot
i'm very careful about what i eat i had
coveted i was okay
um i haven't gotten it again i've been
exposed nothing has happened i'm not a
threat like to to assume that i am an
immediate threat is absurd and i think
if you're going to if you're going to
justify if you're going to utilize
you know say well we need to justify
this mandate based on transmission you
lose if you're going to say we need to
justify this mandate based on what's
happening in hospitals well then you
have a whole host of other issues that
you better be looking at as well because
then your whole population essentially
in this country is going to be affected
in some way because i'm going to get to
say really well i don't tax the hospital
system but somebody who's obese taxes
the hospital system more so what are you
doing about them
where does it end and i think those
stats on hospitalization and death i
think also listen
that yes there are some stats that show
that that is absolutely true you have
some stats coming out of other places
like the uk that show things a little
bit differently in some studies i think
there are people that have benefited
from the vaccine i think there are
people that got the vaccine and maybe
they didn't get coveted or they got a
milder case of code but they got other
stuff i know a lot of people who have
had some in my family some my friends
who have had horrible side effects of
this vaccine horrible truly everything
from myocarditis to blood clots this is
just a reality this is a reality it's a
drug any drug has a list of side effects
that are potential
any drug so by the way again youtube if
you're listening fauci has said that
himself in an interview fauci said
anytime we introduce a new vaccine they
come with side effects and we make it
better as we test this so this is not a
claim this is what faucia said but
antibiotics too i mean this is not new
this is not new antibiotics you can go i
can go to the drug store and take a
pseudo fed
and get deathly ill from it so
yes i mean i've taken listen my mom and
i it was interesting we both had a sinus
infection a few years ago i remember we
both took the same medication i got
horribly sick i was hallucinating she
was fine so you're not in the same body
as someone else so all i'm saying is
which should not be controversial to
anyone make your own decision talk to
your doctor talk to your family talk to
yourself make your own decision if
that's controversial in the united
states in 2022 i don't i don't know what
to say i think what adam's curious is
the sudafed that you were hallucinating
he wants to want some of that i'd like
to have the
i used to do stand-up comedy my dad
thought sudafed was like a wonder drug
oh you broke your arm take some sudafed
not a big deal like headache take some
sudafed oh you got a
sudafed so not that [ __ ] but
my question to you sorry is
is this your new fight meaning before
kovid you didn't talk about vaccines i
doubt that this was something that was
on your radar or was it but is this your
line in the sand like this is what i
stand for now yeah i mean i think my
fight has always been freedom you know i
came into this business battling the gop
establishment really i was battling
republicans my issue was dead my issue
was like why don't they care about the
debt you know specifically republicans
or just politicians well i was mad
because republicans claimed to care
about fiscal conservatives right a lot
of republicans were claiming to care
about those things and weren't doing
anything about it and i saw the rise of
the tea party movement and i know
they've been vilified but i went to a
lot of those rallies and a lot of it
consisted of regular people who were
tired of all of this nonsense
so i think you know freedom has always
been an issue that a hill that i'm
willing to die and i have never seen
anything like this unfold in the united
states of america i saw what happened i
mean i come from new york city
you can't go into a restaurant without
showing a vax car this is the united
states so i have a two-year-old and i
look at him and i'm like you're not
doing this to my kid like i will get out
of here i will take my money not that
it's a lot but i will take my money i
will take what i do for a living i will
get out of here and let these cities
that are doing this to people let them
sink let them figure out that you can't
act this way so this is my hill to die
on not because it's you know i i'm not
someone who's like i'm an anti-vaxxer
you know that's not my position my
position is how are we now in a place in
this country where someone can't make
that decision for themselves and these
pharmaceutical companies that have
liability protection why can't you ask
about that why can't you ask questions
and just say hey why is that the case or
what are the side effects or
gee you know my risk assessment for me
is not the same as the risk assessment
for a 90 year old with four
comorbidities these are not questions
these are questions you're getting
censored for okay are your parents let
me they are let me ask you background so
before fox and view what were you doing
i was teaching really i was i was a
teacher i taught um
spanish actually in schools for six or
seven years it's hard to remember
exactly but in new york city in staten
island and in manhattan
um i was a academic dean high school
dean and um interesting went
interestingly went through six flu
seasons and never a mask was mentioned
even though the flu was more dangerous
to kids than covet but that's a side
note but yeah you know i taught in these
schools so when we talk about like woe
curriculums and all of that
oh yeah that's real who were you in high
school if we were in high school to get
a 10th grade who's jedediah a nerd
okay like four point something gpa
valedictorian type of deal i was the
valedictorian of my college were you
ready yeah yeah i went to wagner college
on staten island i got a 4.0 i literally
i just worked i was i was a i was a
bookworm so i read a lot um i was social
too i had a lot of friends i don't know
if the definition of a nerd like what
you're thinking of i wasn't you know
ronald miller and uh can't buy me love
do you guys know that movie it's amazing
by the way i had a crush on him for the
longest time
i love you you're dating yourself here i
love nerds though like actual nerds like
when did you break out of your shell
because clearly you're not a nerd
clearly you're vocal clearly you've got
a lot going on so college i kind of
discovered you know that i had a little
bit more of a voice i you know started
dating i started living uh still was
very academic though at the time i
thought i was gonna get a phd in spanish
literature i was like i want to be a
professor i love college campuses this
is where i'm going to go went to
columbia got my master's and was like uh
i was wrong columbia yeah so at that
time were you a liberal you're were you
political that was a conservative so
your parents are they conservatives
so
yes my dad is very conservative he's
like a ted cruz
kind of guy um
my mom is a little bit more of a mixed
bag i think you'd you know i think she's
more of like a marco rubio voter if i
had to peg her as one um
but yeah my family was very eclectic
though my grandparents were democrats um
a lot of family friends that we had in
our house you know as family you know
aunts that weren't really ants but were
close friends with my mom and whatnot
most of them were liberal and i grew up
in new york city so i was surrounded by
liberalism it just didn't make sense to
me um
so yeah i went to columbia for for a
master's in spanish literature and
decided it wasn't for me that i loved
literature but i i went and worked for
an insurance company for a while um
yeah i do nothing about it i'm a
terrible i mean really like were you
without here oh my zurich zurich sir i
was with zurich but i did marketing for
them i got you but i mean i used to sell
zurich so i remember zurich yeah i'm not
good at that stuff like if you're going
to ask me about inflation have another
guest on you're not good i feel like you
could be good at anything you do so what
weren't you good at i'm not i just don't
have that kind of head i'm more of a
creative you know
i'm a creative type you know i want to
sit and write short stories all day long
um and essentially what happened was i
worked in
waited tables i you know which was one
of the most fun jobs i ever had in my
life and i made a lot of cash so you
know but tough on your feet tough one i
grew got some good guns though that i've
kept from the you know obviously you
can't really see them in here but i
can't see it through the yeah yeah there
it is i mean
i'm just you know taking myself
but floated around for a little while um
went to la thought i might want to do
some acting chickened out was a big
chicken about that shouldn't have been
wish i had stayed
came back when she would have stayed
wish i would have why
because it's typically the other way
around what she would have i you know
acting was something i loved i grew up
in a house where my mom taught acting
classes to kids
and out of my living room when um when i
was really little she taught
improvisation and i loved it i genuinely
loved it i write about this in my book
dear hartley a little bit trying to
encourage my kid to like if you love
something go for it don't be a coward
like me
but it was hard and i was in l.a i was
with a friend and
i just didn't have the right head and i
i didn't give it my best shot and i
think if i would have stayed i would
have had at least a chance either i
would have had a chance at success or i
would have been able to say i gave it my
all which is always what you want out of
life and you want your kids to know that
too so pat asked you who you were in
high school 10th grade yeah so you know
you kind of you brought up the can like
so were you a melrose place girl 902
90210 okay yeah i saw something
with luke perry rolled up on you rest in
peace i loved him so much yes 90210 100
all the way i was a brenda dillon fan
loved him got to meet him at the view
years later oh my gosh he was like your
husband was in the crowd he was looking
a little
curious my husband was a little a little
jealous i wasn't married at the time
yeah and you were having second thoughts
and my mom said to me that my
now husband looked at her and said
should i should i go up there and she
was like jeremy it's live television
like what are you going to do up there
knock out dylan mckay because i was like
i was very back
but yeah i was 10th grade i was also ran
track i was you know i was social but
i'm not social now this is the most
social i get what's happening right now
jedidiah were you feisty like were you
like were you part of the debate team
were you part of like all of that or not
really i was quite like when i was
really small i never spoke in fact my
first grade teacher called my mom and i
was like is she okay and she's really
smart but she doesn't speak i was very
shy and very afraid of all of that
by the time i got to high school i had a
teacher a politics teacher who i later
found out was like a super liberal but
really encouraged us to to speak out and
i kind of got my voice in that class
um and in college kind of shifted away
did more of a literary journey but i
think that was where i kind of got my
fire
um
and you know years later after i did the
acting came back to new york taught for
a little while the whole the whole
political career started because i was
writing on a blog that had like five
viewers i'm not kidding at one point it
was like five people had seen my article
and one of the articles was reviewing
mark levin's book
and my friend sent it to him and he read
it on air
and a couple of months later like sean
hannity's people called me and were like
does she want to come on the panel and
my mom fainted because my mom loves him
to this day
hannity and i there i was this school
teacher who didn't have a journalism
degree who was a regular girl just
speaking my mind
sitting on a panel and two weeks later
filling in for dana perino in a segment
with stuart varney and i was like i'm
not really sure how
i think there was just a hunger for a
regular voice at that time well ron paul
said the best thing ron paul said
when he was doing what he was doing
full-time as a doctor
he started going and hearing a economist
speak he says when i left every time he
recommended a book i'd go back and read
the book i'd go back and read it now i
said i got obsessed he said so i kept
going back every time he was giving a
speech he said eventually i went up to
the guy said listen
i can't help myself i'm addicted to this
content this just makes a lot of sense
liberty freedom all this stuff he said
this was never things i thought about he
says what do i do with this passion he
says don't worry about it he says keep
talking about it keep writing about it
the right people will find you people
found you so was fox found you first
because the mark live and then the view
came in how how did you how did you
approach it so fox found me first and i
wound up doing a lot of free television
which is what happens in tv everyone
sees that you're on tv and they're like
oh you're a celebrity
you're broke i was broke i had been on a
teacher's salary before that i don't
come from money i grew up in a very
middle class family my parents struggled
to pay the mortgage you know i
didn't have that i didn't have any
connections to the political world like
my parents weren't in politics um
so i did a lot of free tv and then i got
my first contributor deal
over at fox after maybe a couple of
years of doing free television i did not
only free tv at fox i was doing you know
cnbc i was doing um with larry kudlow at
the time i was doing msnbc hits kudlow i
mean that's
serious yeah
conversations right there no i mean
yes but not mine mine were more like
culture we do a panel or but i would
find myself in these places and be like
wow i'm building a career but broke
nobody knows this maybe i should have
told everyone hey make a donation make
it until you make it girlfriend exactly
exactly and i got my first contributor
deal first contributing was small i mean
it's not money that you're making but
you know from there i was due i signed
two deals with fox that were for a
contributor and then the view came
and it's funny i went to roger ailes at
the time and i said you know the view
wants me to come on and guest host and
he typically fox doesn't let you do any
of that stuff but he was like well
i think it'll be really good for the
network you know extra exposure and
you're not gonna get the job
no way yeah because i was so new i was
so green
and i was like okay you know i knew i
had a shotgun did you take that as a
challenge or was it just kind of like
are you like i'm gonna i'm gonna crush
this one show when i get on they're
gonna know i belong here well once he
gave me in writing the approval i was
like wait till he sees what i do
did he become your pat talks about find
your enemy to get motivated right did
that become your enemy proving roger
ailes the legendary great you know
controversial i think your enemy well i
think it was he had launched this huge
television network and you know for a
while i had been i had been a
contributor but i wanted to fill in on
shows like i wanted to host and he was
always like you know you have to earn
your place to do that and here comes
this network tv show that's like
we'll give her a chance and he was like
oh you don't you know almost like
she's too green and i went i got the job
so i love it i love when people are
underestimated so when you go at what
point do they just tell you right there
listen we want to talk no i had to test
there too which i was fine to do because
i was employed i had my fox contract and
i would show you the view i did a few
months of testing um with a bunch of
people that were testing i remember like
um
melissa joan hart was testing i i was it
was like a lot of celebrities yeah at
the time yeah what are they asking me
i'm curious like when they're sitting
there they're interviewing you
do they ask you like so what do you
think about this what do you think is
that kind of a conversation i did an
interview first with candy carter who i
really like she's still at abc she's a
nice she's really nice fun um
and i she asked me a zillion questions
like how do you feel about this and how
do you feel about that and they wanted
you know the claim was that they wanted
diversity of thought on the panel and
they wanted someone who was going to be
tough
to stand up to the other opinions so it
was a very long interview and i left and
i was like
i don't know what happened like i don't
know and then she was like all right
we're going to put you on so they put me
on oh it was long it was like i feel
like i was in there for like a couple
hours honestly it was long and you said
it's a panel or it's just candy well it
was just me and candy for the interview
got it and then um
i think i met with candy i think i met
with brian uh i met with a few people
and they were like okay green light her
let's put her on and see what she does
so i was this girl who had
just a couple of years before that been
writing for a vlog with like five what
was the timeline yeah by the time levin
brought you on you're on hannity a
couple of years okay so you put in some
way but you got no but you got to
realize couple years not a long time
people have to this is very important
for people that are listening to this
look
you know whatever situation you're in
with your life like sometimes
people like the part she talked about
she did so much free tv you know that's
the part a lot of people don't want to
do you're going to have to work and get
underpaid for a long time until you get
your break
and she got a break it's a beautiful
story that's exactly how capitalism
works
that's exactly how your world works
that's how business works when you know
you you pay the price and then they find
you and it goes back to ron paul's story
if you keep talking about what you
believe in they're eventually going to
find you you said tea party earlier was
it like the whole michele bachmann era
yeah that air i wasn't a huge bachmann
fan
i came in you'll hate this probably i
could just tell i just can read people
because i know i no no i guarantee it
but i came in being like a sarah palin
fan um and the reason i was a sarah fan
now i know sarah so i know a little bit
about her no i just see i see you as
someone who probably
i don't think she'd be your first choice
let's just say that but you know what
not only me 99 of america yeah but you
know there's a reason for that because
you've been told what you've been told
about sarah palin and most of it's not
true but regardless i got interested in
sarah palin i'll tell you why because
first of all she just kind of showed up
out of nowhere but i saw that mccain
plucked her out of nowhere because she
wasn't going to be rushed from her
she never said that i wasn't um i wasn't
a mccain
fan look at us having the view
battling it out never said that but um
not that way anyway but yeah i wasn't a
mccain fan but i was like who's this
woman and the only reason she was
interesting to me was because media
couldn't stand her from second one and
they take i saw the takedown and i said
okay let me figure out maybe she's
terrible so i did a bunch of research on
her work in alaska
as mayor and as governor and i was like
okay she's actually quite legit and this
is why they hate her and she's also very
personable and
so i became kind of um interested in
what she brought to the table
um and she also was a soccer mom she she
felt like a regular person to me which i
really liked because i was a regular
person in a business where everyone felt
like you needed some degree i don't have
a journalism degree thankfully i didn't
waste my time doing that but um so
colombia wasn't journalism colombia was
spanish literature spanish literature
that's why you taught that for many
years yeah so we after you met you know
how sometimes you're like oh my gosh
she's so amazing and then after you meet
sarah was what you read and what you saw
the same as the time you spent with
sarah
sarah's just a regular person she's just
a mom she is
a well-intentioned political figure she
makes mistakes she's not always the most
articulate in expressing her ideas all
the time as as neither am i neither is
anyone else it's hard to be in the
spotlight sometimes
she's um she has a great record in
alaska i know they destroyed her once
she went back um a lot of oppo research
i mean the media landed in alaska they
were like we're going to land there
we're going to figure out what's wrong
with her they were reading her emails
line by line by line which is
interesting they had no interest in
hillary clinton's emails but
where she lied repeatedly but can you
imagine like you're being told you're
going to be working out of alaska here's
where you're going that's your job
my question to you on palin
is i actually completely understand why
regular girls soccer mom totally get
that as far as vice president united
states do you think she was a little
over her in a little over her head
no i think she had a really horrible
team around her um
that didn't really support her and i
don't think she really understood i
think she understood establishment
politics in alaska governor of alaska
yeah and she wasn't like a little small
city mayor pete butterjudge you know
south bend indiana that's true and pete
better judge has been glorified for that
limited record that he has that he did
fix a lot of potholes so let's have a
little response there you go took two
months off pat was good
that's interesting though because think
about the way those two people were
viewed one was glorified and covers of
magazines and one was like oh she's not
up to the job she knew a lot about the
establishment in alaska because she was
dealing with the murkowskis and all that
but i don't know that she was prepared
for the national stage and what that was
going to look like i think that was her
team or the mccain i think it was mccain
no i knew her team meg stapleton and all
them but no she yeah but regardless
whether you love her a hater i mean she
was demonized from day the woman didn't
have a chance but just think about
anybody that's announced as a vp go any
go go and go think about what vp people
were like oh my gosh this is fantastic
even pence when they said pence did you
know pence
did you know governors
did you sit there and say that's the
right selection nobody's first pick was
pence nobody's second pick was pence
so mccain
you know like the whole conversation
with giuliani
what giuliani ran on in the first time
he ran for president if he would have
ran on that and that was today giuliani
is a president
if mayor giuliani ran so sometimes it's
also timing uh when you're the first
person that's going to come out as
you're the vp you're a woman you're
going out there
chances are you're probably set in tone
for the next person that's going to go
out there and win it's not you like you
know how you think about friendster uh
facebook before facebook was what
myspace before myspace was friendster
what happened to friends are you still
on friendster yeah i i send you from
freshman i haven't gotten it yet what do
you mean i'm messing with you all day oh
that might be a different patrick
pattern
david patrick yeah by the way you know
you uh so so when you did get hired with
the view yeah is it a contract of do
they pay in the format of one episode is
it a six-month contract is it a
three-month contract what's the con
so i'm trying to remember my contract i
basically had a three-year contract but
at the end of each year they had the
opportunity they had to renew me got it
so um and there you had a guarantee of a
certain number of appearances i wasn't
employed at abc at large i was employed
by the view me personally megan may have
had a different deal how different is
that is that separate yeah because if
you're in it's actually much safer to be
employed by abc at large because then if
something goes wrong with the view you
can utilize that
sense that because at the time frankly i
i didn't makes
don't think i had the credentials to
fight for that and secondly
i wasn't sure how it was going to go and
i wasn't sure what was going to happen
so i was comfortable with the contract
they gave me enrolling in and was it
decent pay was it yes okay so it was it
was a raise which was great yeah this
smile says it says the story
are you still in touch with any of the
ladies on the view
whether it's the conservatives the abbey
huntsman's the mccains the the joy
behar's the whoopies i was um until this
appearance that just happened i mean i i
actually maintained a a pretty you know
decent friendship um with sunny with
sarah
occasionally would exchange with whoopi
and joy
i my time on the show was actually okay
because even though we duked it out
sometimes on air we actually really got
along behind the scenes as a group it
was a cast that really liked each other
yeah so i left and even though i was
fired
um inexplicably overnight
um i didn't hold that against the cast
and there were people that worked there
at the time that aren't there anymore
that were responsible for that um
but i left kind of feeling
like these were still my friends and my
family and i was sad
so i didn't trash them in media i didn't
do any of that and it wasn't really
until this last appearance that i just
felt like wow that was pretty horrible
what happened on air because you guys
knew what i was going to say and i i
really thought i was there to have a
conversation because i know them you
know sunny was at my wedding you know i
know these people and i said if you're
going to invite me and you know what i'm
going to say either say forget it you're
not coming on or let me talk let's have
the conversation who's the biggest
advertiser for the view do you know like
i don't know but i know
you know big farmers and all these
places
sorry but can you google and see who's
the biggest advertiser on the view i
looked it up in 2015 a bunch of
advertisers dropped but that's not the
article i'm looking for i want as recent
as possible let me go back to it from
the day you got fired
how many days prior to that was when you
questioned hillary clinton
oh i think it was four i think i
questioned her on a thursday and lost my
job
on a sunday oh i didn't know that so so
four days after you
you questioned hillary clinton so what
happened there was and i've spoken about
this with um you know
sunny recently that we were like no one
really understood what happened there
and i don't know if it's attributed to
the hillary clinton interview i really
don't i have no idea what year was that
twenties
was it sixteen seventeen it's right
around there she was right running about
what was it or after she lost no no she
was it was after she lost after she lost
she wrote a book called what happened it
was the first live appearance she did on
the view and she asked the question oh
yeah that's right i saw that yeah i
asked the question i had i had just
re-upped like that summer you know you
had to like i said they had to renew you
even though you had a three-year
contract they had to renew you so i
signed the paperwork i was like okay i
guess i'm in for another year and that's
the way i view this business you never
know you could be out tomorrow you know
so i was like okay in for another year
i asked what i thought was a pretty
benign question i asked her i said
listen you know you're saying you're
acting like you're surprised that trump
won but it sounds a little tone deaf to
me because i was talking to people
around the country who were disgusted
with a lot of what was going on like
looking back do you see that maybe these
people voted because they they didn't
like what was happening in the prior
administration i thought that was a
pretty fair question
her face said otherwise i didn't even
get to ask about her emails which was
really what i was there was a little bit
of panic at the show that day because i
was like well can we show here that she
signed a piece of paper that said she
knows what these classifications mean
and she's denied that she knew them but
her signature and they were like i
wouldn't do that i wouldn't do that
there was a little bit of worry that it
was going to be combative
but don't they like that is that like
the whole point of the view they want to
see
i think the perception is that but
actually i think there's a lot of
protection that goes on on shows like
that for political figures for point of
views
so i didn't get to that but i asked the
tone-deaf question and then four days
later i actually got a call from someone
who worked in media i think i think it
was oliver darcy actually if i'm not
mistaken who wrote who called me and was
like there's a rumor that like megan
mccain's taking your job and i was like
oh well that can't be i just i was like
what and i wrote my producer and he was
like oh we'll get on it pr i don't even
think the ep of the show knew
no one knew the ep of this
and my eps like candy and brian were
like
really quite nice to me and were like
listen
i don't know and i believed them and i
still believe them because they're i
really do um
so i don't know what happened i don't
know if it's related to that i don't
know if that was the icing on the cake i
don't know if there were talks going on
and then suddenly someone decided oh
great and also that interview didn't
help i don't really know just the timing
seemed so awesome so when did you when
did you sign the next year what
was in the summer
summer how many like weeks or months
before the hillary clinton uh uh it was
in august i don't remember it was
several weeks before that oh so so this
is fresh so you sign it's not like it's
six months no no no it was several weeks
got it so they had already committed to
having you on for another year yeah so
it wasn't like behind closed doors they
were talking to megan
listen i maybe for all i know i mean
there are people that have since been
fired from there that we're doing pretty
horrible things that's come out in the
news
who i think probably were being
underhanded about it in many ways i
don't know i don't know what
conversations were and weren't going on
i just
it kind of changed my perception of
media because i always felt like a
contract was a contract and all of a
sudden i realized which was helpful for
the future like
okay you're here today you could be gone
tomorrow so just keep that in mind some
people would say just be happy you're
sitting here because maybe you pissed
off the wrong person you know because
there's certain people in politics you
don't piss off because they have a
reputation you know that's right and
that reputation is a multi-dimensional
type of a reputation if you know what
i'm talking about everyone off so i'm in
bad shape maybe i'll come work here you
know
pull up the article
uh on uh
uh
yesterday new york post hillary clinton
democrats are preparing her to run i
don't know if you saw that article did
you see that yeah i'm curious to know
good pull it up let's let's read it
and uh uh did you see this or no adam i
have not adam okay go
there you go press control plus to make
it a little bigger hillary clinton
versus donald trump 2024 yep life has
become a horror movie
a good great title
all right so we are officially a horror
movie where the monsters never dies the
virus never ends and the next election
sees hillary clinton says donald trump
yes the two most polarizing presidential
nominees at the modern time refused to
go away clinton and trump are more
likely than they realize namely they
each live in a reality of their own
making trump continues to insist that
tony tony election was stolen hillary
but he said she won in 2016.
what i was doing was working she told
new york magazine 2017 of bernie sanders
donald trump said i beat both of them
back then i called hillary norma desmond
of american politics ever ready for her
close-up while knuckling her grip on a
scene
that uh long ago rejected her as she
refused to rule out 2020
party leaders were vocal about moving on
job and i never thought she was a great
candidate chuck schumer when you lose to
someone who has 40 popularity you don't
blame other things you blame yourself
wow so
so so this is this is pretty interest do
you think this is a real story or do you
think this is just kind of like new york
post wanted to write a story so people
will talk about but she's not going to
be run it you know i wouldn't put it
past her she's so tone deaf that it
wouldn't surprise me not only would it
not surprise me if she ran again but it
wouldn't surprise me if she ran again
and did the exact same stuff she did you
know multiple other times skipped states
just you know was totally you know
not paying attention to the actual
issues that people care about that would
be a great movie the problem is like
we're in pretty distressed times right
now like i mean
look i i the person i think should run
for rep i want to see ron desantis up
there i really do
um
i think he's done an amazing job and i
think he takes no garbage and he holds
media accountable but he also like knows
when to get out of his own way the
problem with trump and you know i took
plenty of heat for criticizing trump and
it wasn't policy that i was criticizing
chris wallace chris wallace you made a
comment about how he was complaining
about chris i was tired of all of i was
just he couldn't get out of his own way
often times you called him a third
grader yeah because you know the name
calling and all of that stuff it was
just you know it's funny sometimes and
you know it revs up the base and if
you're going to a rally it can be like
oh ha ha trump made a joke but
you know the bottom line was if he would
have just stepped back and let his
record speak for itself and just know
when to just pivot away it's not about
you it's not about a petty battle on
twitter that kind of drove me nuts after
a while so my issue wasn't with policy
on him it was with character and just
like come on man just step away and let
let let these these successes be
successes so desantis you know i like
governors in these positions because
they've actually run something
and i really like him i've seen many
interviews where he's just like that's
not what's happening you know these are
the facts this is what we're doing in
florida this is the model for a free
nation and a free society
so um that's what i'm a fan of and
listen i always welcome a hillary
clinton run it's a guaranteed disaster
guarantee biden is a disaster you're
saying no chance she runs wait wait did
you just say no chance she was tone deaf
as she is really to to remix it running
back
do you think you think the democratic
party wants her back no you think
there's you know fervor for her
joe biden i don't even think i don't
even think
clearly the democrats need to figure out
who's in their stable clearly we talked
about
michelle obama potentially being a
candidate i've i've never thought that
she was going to run ever now i'm like
well you know if there's ever a time
control over i don't i think she runs
she could win i don't think again same
thing i don't think she wants to give up
that life would you vote for trump in
against two yeah
yeah or anyone anyone anyone whoever the
democrats throw up there
this child never i will never vote for a
big government democrat ever i will
never vote for a big government so
my problem with trump is you know i have
to listen to what trump says and trump
we already know what he's going to say
so yeah and now he's on the vaccines odd
comments and this that i think what i
will say is today and i can't tell you
what i'm going to do next round i know i
often do a lot of write-ins because i'm
like oh these people all are just
terrible but i can't tell you what i'm
going to do today because i don't know
in that situation but my my guy is
desantis okay
again his wife has health issues that
he's dealing with right now and he's
attending to right now uh if trump runs
the one thing i think it'd be very
uncomfortable to see is a stage with
trump and desantis together because i
don't think that's going to be a good
scene no uh if those two aren't the same
it'll be good for desantis
yeah i think it'd be great for tv no
it'd be great
because desantis is is basically going
to tout
policy better than trump he has a very
strong record and he also isn't going to
stoop to that nonsense so he's going to
look like the adult in the room is the
honest truth i've been very vocal that
someone like me was somewhere in the
middle a lot of people on this thing
thumb camera socialist communist i'm
just not a trumper guy
i would 100 vote for desantis and i
would also 100
not vote for a trump do you understand
what i'm saying right there like
desantis got you young vibrant policy
smart florida what's up let's do it
trump really we're going to run back
that horror movie from 20 you know 2016.
so that's something that so let me ask
you a question here's a question for you
trump hillary what are you doing
again yeah if it's trump hillary what
are you doing
i would vote for hillary yeah you would
seriously i would
so i can absolutely tell you i would not
trump listen if i would trump hillary i
think hillary actually has good policies
i think she's
tone deaf and not exactly you know gonna
circle the wagons to the midwest go
ahead do you want to play this game no
no i'm just saying can we get a hillary
shirt for him can you actually make it
with her yeah let's get her shirt for
him let's go
make a note next trump hillary for me
like i'm voting for trump he's not my
ideal i think he made a lot of mistakes
i held him accountable for those
mistakes on live tv many times he's not
my guy i'm not like maggot you know i
don't do that with any politician
but except for uh rand paul
no i'm also not wearing a rand paul hat
here today you know what i mean like
that's not my favorite we get her a rand
paul had asap
now
get me um yeah rand paul in the front
and sarah palin on the back do you think
rand paul stands a chance at all for
ever being an op in office tell me why
tell me why if you you say no what do
you think does he stand a chance to be
president president number one no chief
no no i like him i like him and i like
what he's doing but on the debate stage
it just doesn't work he shrinks on the
debate stage really
wise no no i mean like he just kind of
vanishes and i feel like he i remember i
always tweet through these debates and i
remember feeling like he
all of those issues that he really does
care about like freedom and these are
things he lives
it he has trouble connecting to the
audience on those things like i want to
see someone who people feel like
you need to be charismatic in politics
you need to be someone that people feel
like that person gets me
can i tell you something about pat and
this is something that he's taught me
and i'll let you you know weigh in on
this there's a difference between policy
and personality and persona and
you know we we have this debate all the
time most people vote on
persona personality
rand paul might have amazing policies
but people are going to be like he's
just born in in the days of reality tv
social media you need to be a big
vibrant loud mouth mother sucker
in order to sway the masses clearly
trump did that you know what's
interesting i mean about what you're
saying i agree with you but that
standard oftentimes only applies to
republicans because kamala harris is
terrible at this she laughs
inappropriately well she also got joe
biden is terrible at this he's in office
right now some of these democrat hillary
clinton is a horrible candidate like
find me someone off the random person
off the street and they will do that
better than she does horrible at being a
political candidate bernie's pretty loud
mouth and did his thing and kind of
grumpy i mean that wouldn't work on the
right i'll tell you
why you need to be like what you have to
be clint you sweat on the right you have
to be luke perry basically i mean
did you see her eyes like literally
flutter as you brought up my husband's
at home watching like i saw that
but i'm sure you've had many sides by
the way luke perry or chris isaac
because chris isaac showed up do you
remember chris isaac or no chris isaac
who
the video he had this video that jukebox
would play all the time and you would
not miss it
on the beach
something the game the crying game
wicked game that's wicked wicked game
okay
that was 36 songs by the way
i think he did put in chris isaac
beverly hills 90210 am i just losing my
mind here possibly i thought he was
isaac with a k yeah he was on beverly
hills 902 i know i was right you missed
that you messed that up wait oh he what
no i definitely saw the episode i'd have
to see where it was pat you were saying
about personality persona yeah so so she
has a point because the last election
again the last election wasn't about
personality i don't think anybody showed
up to buy rally everybody that showed up
got a 50 gift certificate to cheesecake
factory
but it was media really made you hate
trump so they showed up against him
there was no personality or policies you
go to hillary it wasn't personality she
didn't focus on policy the question she
asked in the view which she should see
the question she has she said do you
think one of the reasons why maybe again
i'm
paraphrasing
is because
obama's policies on
obamacare didn't work out and then as
well as you were focused so much against
him versus he was focused on policies
and that's why he lost do you think
that's what really happened and then she
said maybe a little bit and she want to
give her answers but i think hillary
didn't focus on policies hillary hillary
was more about let's make the first
woman the first female that was her
campaign it was never policy so she's
not going to win she went on zach
galifianakis i don't know if you saw
that one when she was on california
between two firms between two ferns did
you ever see that one
sadly
no no no so she tried to play the obama
playbook okay
the difference is obama went on there
and he had charm and he won
hillary went on there and he says i'm
sorry we got to take a break for our
advertisers and he plays the trump video
he says this is this is brought to you
by our sponsor donald trump i don't know
if you remember that was hilarious right
and then she's like what are you doing
what do you do it's all about but it was
so funny and her rebuttal wasn't the
right one like you just didn't like her
she's awkward yeah she's awkward and
uncomfortable enough very robotic bill
clinton was likable bush senior screwed
up because he was kind of like the out
of touch president and ron paul kind of
hurt him a little bit when that question
was asked about that reagan had charm
and charisma and humor probably more
than anybody else in the last 50 years
bush was
bush was kind of quirky funny likable
like hey i want to have a beer with this
guy president jr yeah junior he was
different you know he was different and
he literally did have a beer with him
yeah yeah we had a great time together
but but uh uh today the question becomes
who do we want today like what does
america look for today midterms is going
to be a shellacking by the way did you
guys see the article that came out about
spain and europe what they're doing with
covet did you see what which is which
one okay pull up that article about
yesterday very interesting by the way
very and this tells you a lot but what
could happen in america
go to it's a bloomberg article i just
emailed it to you
uh uh there uh that's the one click on
that check this out pretty interesting
europe slowly starts to consider
treating kovy like the
new metrics are needed as kovit becomes
endemic spain pm sets by the way spain
is a socialist country
okay their former president left because
they raised taxes so high so we're not
talking about a capitalistic nation
hospital hospitalization rates remain
manageable despite surging cases spain
is calling for coca-19 to be treated uh
as an endemic disease like the flu
becoming the first major european nation
to explicitly suggest that people live
with it the idea has gradually uh been
gaining traction and could prompt a
revaluation of government strategies on
dealing with the virus british education
secretary
nadahim
zahawi on sunday told bbc that the uk is
on path towards transitioning from
pandemic to endemic to omicron variant
low variance lower hospitalization and
death rates uh despite record infections
prompts prompt the spanish prime
minister pedro sanchez to hold out the
tantalizing prospect of europe moving
beyond dependence on restriction on
normal life by the way very very good
news what does endemic mean meaning it's
like to the end of it like you're not
getting rid of covid like this idea
and i think it's important to remember
how this started it was like two weeks
to flatten the curve and that meant a
couple of weeks you were going to do a
lockdown i was somebody that was on
board with that by the way in the
beginning i was like okay
everybody was because it was so new and
so like what the hell is going on right
two weeks flatten the curve and that
meant okay we're going to flatten it
we're going to get these
hospitalizations down we're going to get
treatments out there although we now
know that a lot of treatments were
suppressed it's a whole other
conversation but regardless you know it
was okay now it's what two years later
and we're i mean some teachers unions
are advocating for teachers not to do
in-person teaching in the united states
of america so this is right this is
right it's endemic yes it's endemic and
omicron for the vast vast vast vast vast
majority of people of all age brackets
is a cold that is what it is it is a
cold for most people
and we've never had bad absolutely
true but for bad colds do you do you not
have in-person learning for children do
you not have people going to work i mean
this is crazy at this point so what
they're doing great some of us have been
saying this for months and months and
months and it's not happening in the
united states why is it not now well now
you see a little bit it was a report
that the ap came out and said let's not
focus on cases
anymore let's not it's how convenient
you had a death tracker up on cnn for
how long well of course you're not going
to focus on cases because a lot of these
cases are asymptomatic people or people
with mild symptoms and that's not an
indication of anything except that yeah
covet is around omicron is around people
are getting it they're feeling a little
bit sick a few days later they're better
a lot most people
most people
so you know media has changed you're
going to see a lot of manipulation come
because they have to protect joe biden
and joe biden said he was going to get
rid of the virus and he didn't because
he wasn't going to get rid of the virus
and trump wasn't going to get rid of the
virus no one was going to get rid of the
virus trump also said that it's going to
be here today and gone tomorrow by july
4th we're all going to be going to
easter together but but here's what i
would say so guess what america fired
them right which is which is fine which
is fine but check this out
here's the part and i posted this the
other day on the tweet
i said i look for constant this is very
important to keep talking about this
because
we had under trump when covet came out
the worst day in cases was 300 000 cases
i think was january 28 of 2021 which he
was still president pre-inauguration
right 300 000 cases in a day the worst
day under biden has been a million
eighteen thousand in a day which was
nine days ago eight days ago million
eighteen in a single day
so trump got fired obama's the next
president who has been constantly biden
as president trump got fired who has
been constant during these two
administrations
and by the way
here's here so i brought this up
conversation with some people i was in
vegas yesterday i just got back from
vegas last night 11 o'clock i got back
to the place we had an insurance
conference and
we're having this conversation one guy
works at the uh emergency room in uh
maryland and he's a doctor and we're
having this debate of what's going on
fauci so
you make a decision on what to do with
this whole situation of the virus on how
to handle it you go back and you look at
what he did with aids you go back and
look at what he do with all this stuff
i'm not even gonna go there just go read
the book by rfk the truth about uh fouch
if you haven't read it if you're
interested now i think it's a very good
book it's a long book but it's a very
it's worth to read i went through the
book it's fascinating here's the part i
don't think that position moving forward
i'm comfortable being one person i don't
think i'm comfortable with that like a
supreme court i think it's the supreme
court model i'm comfortable it's a 3-2
it's a 4-3 it's 80 years old it's 4-3
and you guys sit there so guess what on
one side you have somebody that's part
of peter mccullough camp you know you
got somebody that's part of a malone
camp you got somebody that's part of
that camp on the other side you got a
fouchy you got any of these guys that
are there no problem sit down hash it
out
let us let congress people question both
of you and let us kind of sit down and
hear it but right now the only person's
argument we are allowed to hear
is tony's that's right and in business
you know what you would call that you
know what you call monopoly you would
call that a monopoly and what do we do
monopoly story came out just yesterday
that's the government right now it's
breaking apart facebook saying whatsapp
instagram you cannot evolve and by the
way i think they're right as a
capitalist but as a capitalist i think
this guy's got the biggest monopoly and
it's hurting america and i think if
here's a crazy prediction for you if
check this out adam curious you know
what you would say about this
jedi i imagine we wake up tomorrow
morning pre-midterms tomorrow friday
announcement made
the biden administration is have decided
to part ways with
fauci and a new person is going to be
replacing him okay and they'll be
announcing it next week or two
how do you think america is going to
react if that were to happen actually
think about and by the way so so you
have the people on the left the 47
percent you have the people on the right
who are 44 they're not going to change
their positions the 44 is going to be
ecstatic the 47 is going to be that's
the dumbest decision you ever made i'm
talking about the middle
take the libertarians at the green party
i'd say the middle 12 percent how is the
middle 12 percent going to react if they
announce tomorrow that fauci is fired
well
do you think they're gonna react yes i
do i actually do because he's so
horrible and i think people know but it
depends on who goes in there
and you're what you're saying about you
know put someone who's like fouchy put
someone who's like malone let them hash
it that will never happen because these
people are big farmer mouth mouthpieces
end of story that's who founty is he is
a big pharma mouthpiece he has lied
repeatedly to people about a number of
issues over and over and over again he
lied about what the vaccine was capable
of he lied about what it was incapable
of he lied about masks he's telling
people don't see your unvaccinated
family members why vaccinate everyone i
know who's vaxxed has either can get it
they're spreading it it's happening all
over the place why
so i think there's a lot of people in
the country that distrust him and want
him out but they also distrust the
system at large and they don't believe
they're questioning now big pharma at
large is people who never thought to ask
questions about this stuff who are now
saying
wait a minute why why is there liability
protection for x y and z why is there no
accountability from big pharma why are
they allowed to tout statistics and
whatnot and then if those statistics go
down the toilet two months later they
don't have any accountability for what's
actually gone on
so
i actually think the population would
love that but they would be like okay
well who is it now and i don't believe
that the blind administration would ever
put someone forth
that would be neutral
neutral is dangerous well and they so
they tried that with corona they had
remember the task force yeah they had
like six or seven people on the task
force and the lady who wore the scarf
every day yeah deborah berkshire
you had everybody else and the only
there was everybody was in conjunction
except for one scientist was was uh
scott atlas and and they also they
squashed him not only did they squash
him but they squashed all of the doctors
and the great barrington uh great
barrington agreement it's called or
whatever it's called declaration great
barrington declaration that we're coming
out and saying let's focus on the
vulnerable here but you you can't lock
down a whole society you can't do this
to kids who are not at risk of this
infection i mean kids have a 99.997
plus survival rate to cover 19 and that
is when you're even counting deaths as
with covet as opposed to from kovitz so
they're not interested in what you're
suggesting that is not interesting to
them what they want is
this is the path
people that we know that we want their
pockets lined are going to get their
pockets lined they also wanted fear and
despair in the population they wanted
people scared terrified feeling like
you're not going to back mandates and
lockdowns unless you are terrified
so they needed the country scared even
if that wasn't justified and now you see
them coming out and saying oh you know
half the people in new york hospitalized
with covid actually weren't hospitalized
for covert they just incidentally tested
positive and many of them were
asymptomatic or mildly symptomatic that
had nothing to do with why they were
being hospitalized they needed you to
believe differently because division
breeds loyalty to a regime division
breeds loyalty to
very intrusive policies that that stand
to overtake your entire life and they
needed that and now they're realizing
that people are just awake because
they're like wait a minute you told me
this this didn't happen you told me if i
got vaccinated i wasn't going to get
sick i got sick anyway
this doesn't make sense so they're
having to walk back their stats now and
you're going to see collusion between
the cdc and the bite administration and
the teachers unions eventually they're
going to roll in late
on all of these talking points and media
you're going to see the ap you're going
to see you already see it it's cnn jake
tapper coming out and asking all of a
sudden he has these questions
come on it's it's
strategically colluded between all of
these people and they would have never
ever allowed for dissent in those spaces
and think about big pharma perspective
too and the money that would have been
stood to lose there because if you ask
questions even just say empowering
people
to do their own risk benefit analysis
there would have been people that got
vaccinated anyway my parents would have
gotten vaccinated anyway that was a
decision they made which by the way i
supported them in that decision i made
those appointments for them i drove them
to those appointments but there would
have been people who didn't want the
vaccine but got it for work because they
couldn't put food on the table for their
families otherwise that would not have
gotten yeah they get fired because right
well how about all now they're putting
coveted positive nurses and doctors oh
if you're asymptomatic but you have
coveted you can go back into the
hospital because there's shortages you
fired covert recovered nurses and
doctors who weren't that's a work long
term though they're not going to win
like that though jedidiah it's not going
to happen no look what's happening with
kyrie irving right now he's laughing it
up sitting on the side by the way let me
tell you salute to him for not
giving in succumbing to i cannot give i
cannot tell you how much i respect the
fact that the guy who to me and i'm
telling you right now i'm not a kyrie
fan you've heard what i've said about
this is this is a guy that's like i
don't care about this i don't care about
this the fact that he said no i'm not
taking it and the nba had to pivot and
adjust and say what
fine you can play i don't think he still
can't play in new york city doesn't
matter he's gonna run long term he's
gonna he's proven he's the one that's
making progress not the nba his argument
is making progress not the nbas the nba
gave in to him and said okay fine go
ahead because the nba owner said listen
man like we you got to let this guy play
and we're going to get this guy to play
i'm a capitalist i got to run my
business i i'm paying this guy 19 20
million a year right i'm paying this guy
to complain other cities just don't have
vax mandates he played i think his first
game was indiana indiana's like all
right it doesn't matter but here here's
here's the angle that that kind of it's
interesting to me so i'm a fan of bernie
sanders as a person hear me out hear me
out where i'm going with this
i i i had a communist on i've had a lot
of communists i probably interviewed six
or seven communists right sometimes
that's what pat does on the weekends
debates comments are fun i would love to
know how many of those videos were
pulled i'm guessing none none of them
they're all on absolutely that's so
surprising to me
what a great research we just did in two
seconds she's right none of them have
been pulled but i have these commies on
and i interview them and i'm curious to
know what they think and i respect the
ones that are true believers the ones
that are just phony trying to sound like
they're you know you'll catch them very
quickly within 30 minutes you're full of
[ __ ] you're not really talking about
right okay so you're just acting up but
some of the guys you talk you're like
okay cool i respect it i think bernie's
a true believer you know what's
confusing to me with bernie why i think
a bernie and
a bernie n and aoc in the most strangest
way are necessary let me explain why
aoc the other day called that not the
other day about five weeks ago called
that pelosi saying congress you know
people in politics shouldn't be able to
you know uh trade better because yeah
because we have insider informants just
like no i'm gonna i'm gonna invest you
can't tell me anything i'm gonna do it
right
but by the way other people are now
coming in and somebody not jim jordan
who was a guy that maybe even jim jordan
who called that pelosi recently not jim
jordan the other guy
there's meadows i don't know i don't
know who was pull up to see who just
called that pelosi here's where i'm
going with this
do you know the medicine azt
azt was for ages i only know sudafed
that's all okay that's right but azt
azt was a a
pill they came up with for aids which by
the way some claim
330 000 people died from this like
remember accutane had a lot of side
effects like this is like times you know
a lot higher people died from taking
aids medications taking aids medication
but here's the part when they built this
medicine when they finally came out with
this medicine do you know how much it
cost them to make each pill
two cents
is what it costs them to make penny
selling it for a hundred bucks a pill no
ten thousand dollars
and and guess guess who was for it a guy
named fauci yeah so a person that
shouldn't be for
what fauci is doing is in a random way
i think an aoc if a and a bernie sanders
if they come together and they realize
that this guy is simply supporting
big pharma
aoc and bernie could play a very
important role in a fouchy no longer
being here because bernie keeps talking
about what what does bernie say how
could you charge so much with this
medicine how could you charge so much
do you realize that's the billionaire
distance 60 cents to make but they're
selling you four thousand dollars okay
bernie i agree with you i'm with you
you're right keep pushing the envelope
because the guy that's endorsing and
allowing these things to happen because
here's what happens with them they got
20 different products that's being
pitched hey this could be the cure for
this but i'm only looking at the five
that i want to deal with because it's
got i'm not spending time investigating
these other ones so my resources are
being used for this five but these other
15 they're cheap cost effective
less side effects less testimony no not
right now maybe year from now maybe two
years from now maybe three years from
now so i think the possibility of fauci
getting fired
could be high and in the most random
weirdest way i think the people that can
help that happen is bernie and aoc
the thing is though bernie and aoc and
you're you're right i mean these are not
these should not be big pharma allies
they should be sounding the alarm on all
this stuff but the problem is is that
they're benefiting from the chaos the
division and the panic again
part of all of this is is panic right
you know because there are treatments
available now we shouldn't be panicked
now this is not march of 2020. there are
treatments available there are
monoclonals there are drugs that we know
yes ivermectin has been used
successfully i know joe rogan took a
bunch of hits but it's true there have
been numerous studies on that there's
hydroxy which people have taken there's
other treatments that are available for
people now
if you take that panic away if you take
that division away communism cannot
thrive
you can it can't it needs that because
you have to believe that the state is
for it you have to believe that it's the
state
it's what fauci says these people are
sheep they walk around they're like i
don't know what to do do i double mass
do i shield do i triple mass they need
that
so if you remove that and all of a
sudden aoc starts questioning big pharma
people will start realizing well wait a
minute was this a lot of this did a lot
of this have to do with money did a lot
of this have to do with suppression of
treatments did we really need to be
panicking for this long
condition i wanna see what you're gonna
see i'm gonna push back and see what
you're gonna say
so
um how many people on the right would
like to see a third party
none
on the right no i mean i mean listen
like let me ask you a question yes there
are people but it's not in a majority
because they know that a third party
will enable a democrat success but now
let me ask the other question how many
people on the left would like to see a
third party you don't think so okay well
this is my
idea on what i'm thinking that i i do
believe both sides want to see a third
party hear me out hear me out here
i think
aoc
is sick and tired of these democrats
that are getting in the way
and i think aoc is convinced they're
never going to buy in to what she's
bought into ever
and i think aoc is eventually going to
sit there and say you know what i'm loud
enough
i got a bigger mic i get more likes i
get more eyeballs i have more followers
i got the younger audience you don't i'm
sexier i'm more attractive i talk better
i speak better and i'm a true believer
and i'm going to get these guys to be
convinced we need a third party so
what's the third party a third party say
democratic socialist party comes out
let's just say i'm just throwing this
out there
speculation right
i think
where where that 12
of america wants to go to that i think
america's run by 12 percent i don't
think america is run by anything else
but the 12 percent in the middle east
i think 12 runs america i think all the
other guys are just wasting time 12
percent of america runs america period
it's a 12 that was like you know what i
don't know about trump let me go over
here it's the twelve percent i said you
know i don't know about obama let's go
to trump that's the twelve percent the
twelve percent right everybody else is
just talking ohio michigan wisconsin i'm
talking 12
is the one that runs the country
i think if it gets to the tipping point
where these guys are eventually sitting
there having a strategy session because
i think the four you know what it called
the four the four girls what's the the
i think if those guys are sitting behind
closed doors and saying hey girls
you know what let's do it let's go let's
go all out here's what we should do now
you're shaking your head no i i see
we're going with this i'm telling you
right now i actually think that's good
for america
i actually think it's good for america
if some of those guys go and some of the
people from the right go because i think
the left
right i think the right from the right
they're like screw this i want to be a
libertarian i'm going to go independent
let's push let's actually bank on
bringing a ron paul not a ron paul a uh
uh uh
the founder of the internet what's the
guy uh um
the guy that
is not al gore
ross pro let's get the next ross perot
true believer a shamath type of guy a
you know person like that's like screw
republicans screw democrats i'm an
independent i'm a real independent that
can make sense that's a salesperson that
can get you to say this makes sense like
you're saying rand paul doesn't he's so
intellectual that he can't speak the
language of the average person
believe it or not i think there's gonna
be some positive happening
from some of these socialists because
they're not for big pharma and and if
you have to look at enemies like if you
can if you sit there right now make a
list of enemies like concerns like if
you you know uh uh if you sit there and
you go you got i don't know if you guys
got kids or no she's one kid one could
really appreciate two years older that's
the name of her book you're hardly yeah
that's right my baby who are you writing
down over there you wrote an enemy down
i feel like no no no no no i wrote a
little note for myself he's two people
i got a nine eight five and a six and a
half month old baby right now you're not
exhausted oh
you vampires my eyes don't see anything
but anyway so so here's here's where i'm
going with this i think those guys
are ambitious enough to believe that and
i think if we look at the current
enemies look at the list of top 10
enemies like you're raising kids and he
said who are the enemies of me raising
kids well what school am i going to put
them teachers like weird things you
think as a enemy of a kid a teacher
a friend a coach
a sunday school teacher like you got to
be kind of keeping your eyes open to see
who's there right uh
son of a friends you know kids like some
of that stuff okay who are the long-term
enemies of america of us okay so one is
silicon valley you have to put that on
that list
uh two is what let's say socialist okay
fine
big pharma has got to be in the top ten
okay china lobby has got to be in the
top 10 china is at the number one spot
right you got to put russia's probably
in the top ten iran's probably in the
top 15
but you have to put big farm on that
list so now how do you play against them
the way the way this happens on holding
them accountable
is when both sides kind of team up and
say you know what no it took you five
cents to make this ten thousand dollars
is just too much abuse and all these
health insurance costs you guys keep on
increasing i have a lot of employees
every year i'm paying more health
insurance and i have the
the friction with the employee well my
health insurance is going up i'm like
dude i didn't increase your health
insurance 30
this is what's increasing the health
insurance i think there are certain
things that those two sides can disrupt
big pharma i don't know i maybe maybe i
had too much sudafed this
morning know what it is shout outs
right here everything you're saying
anyways i may be i may be confused and
lost but i think my point makes sense so
here's the problem with that though if
that segment of the left you're talking
about the aoc is the bernie sanders if
they're going to come out and criticize
big pharma they're going to come at it
from the perspective of the solution is
socialized medicine the solution for
government the solution is medicare for
all that's a problem that's going to
appeal
it'll appeal to some it will enrage
others also they're going to have a
really hard time
doing that because they need the support
if you're going to criticize big pharma
you also have to criticize the fda you
also have to criticize collusion that
goes on between government organizations
and institutions and these
pharmaceutical companies and how really
intrinsically linked they often are
they're not going to do that so the the
right is
the people on the right who criticize
big pharma will come in and say
well they'll talk about profits but
they'll talk about the answers to a lot
of this is innovation is choice is
freedom is opportunity the people from
the left who criticize big pharma are
going to say well they're all about
profit and the way that we fix this is
that we remove profit and then you have
socialized medicine where people are
waiting you know lines and lines and
lines and you have government deciding
for you instead of big pharma deciding
for you what you need you need this you
need that you're going to have
government deciding it for you and yeah
maybe it'll be less expensive but i
don't know that the outcome is any
different so
i think it's very tricky i don't my my
question is always
how much support i know aoc is popular
she's on tick tock she's talking to
young people most of what she says to me
makes absolutely no sense if i mean i
encourage her to come and sit and have a
debate with me i think it would be
really great television most of what she
says can easily be pushed back on and
makes very little sense but who
how much of the country actually is is
going to support someone like that
because i do think there are a lot of
people who will and a lot of people who
won't but my concern is
what does that number look like what is
that percentage are we now seeing in
america where these mandates and this
way of life and this shift towards
socialism is increasingly much more
popular so that someone like an aoc she
ultimately decides one day she wants to
run for president actually has a chance
and what does that look like i don't
know i think no i don't i think
we're really very split right now in the
united states of america and you all you
need to do is you know what everybody
out there take a trip to new york city
and spend three days there and then come
out to you know miami head out to
dallas texas and just see the two
completely different worlds we're living
in but i don't
i don't know how helpful it is i don't
know i mean i always think splitting up
political parties has an advantage
because you force people to actually
stand for something
um but the allegiances will be the same
right like aoc needs the teachers unions
the the establishment democrat needs the
teachers unions aoc needs government
agencies the democrat establishment
needs government agencies that's why
these third parties don't work
oftentimes because they're out there on
their own
they have to break all of those ties and
then and then who's funding them where
are their donations coming from the
people could work i don't know well i
mean that's that's the good part because
neither bernie nor aoc are getting
checks from the big from big pharma
again that's the part where you got to
respect where it's a lot of smaller guys
are giving them the money right the
government though
i i totally get it but the part is it
doesn't matter if if the two if the two
groups can unify on one enemy one is
going to pitch this is why the
government's got to take care of it the
other one's going to say no
you got to make the barrier to entry to
compete a lot low because these guys are
not helping the smaller companies come
up and compete against advisor compete
against this guy it's pretty much a
control at the top right so meaning for
the longest time
tell me one automaker that competed in
america when's the last time in
automaker competed in america when's the
last time you know how many years it's
been do you know how many years it's
been that a new automaker comes out and
whoops some ass
no no no prior to that where to tesla
you're saying who was it naming delorean
an american company yeah who an american
not an american company comes out and
competing other than the big three other
than gm chrysler yeah tell me one nobody
i can't even think do you realize how
many years that is so what happens with
tesla what's the best thing that
happened with america elon musk tesla
comes out disrupts the automotive
industry they're they're scared they're
sitting there saying holy freaking molly
uh biden and his administration holds an
eevee meeting and at the white house
they invite chrysler they invite ford
they invite gm and the only guy they
don't invite is the guy that disrupted
the ev
elon musk so how necessary is an elon
musk very necessary but he's not a
politician
so here's the thing but i'm saying what
i'm saying
i'm saying if the two like like but elon
musk is also not a republican right
right right right right right right
right right right right right is
probably independent he's not a
republican you can't sit there as a
republican right all i'm saying is
i think
the people on the right anything they
say about big pharma the left is going
to say what yeah they're going to say
something like that well how about the
fact that you know ruber you know
murdoch and what fox is doing but if an
aoc and a bernie says that then
democrats have to sit there and say oh
maybe bernie's right yeah this is true
this is like this whole thing right now
the confusion with my body my choice
right
what is my body my choice right
my body my choice is what is hey if i
want to get an abortion it's up to me
you're right look at the hypocrisy in
the last 12 months yeah you're right my
body
my choice
and that that's a debate
that's a little bit different too um
because and people always say well my
body my choice you're right there is a
lot of hypocrisy from people who would
argue who would support abortion but
then would turn around and tell you to
you know the vax mandates are totally
legit but the difference with that is
also because
people will come out and say well that
involves another person you know if
you're pregnant that involves another
life that's a whole different pro-life
argument that would have to be brought
in and you know debated but i understand
what you're saying but i don't think
i think that what you would be
suggesting would imply that these
politicians are principled and don't
have those underlying ties to
establishment x y and z throughout like
i don't think aoc is someone who's out
there you saw a year ago i remember she
was making headlines she was going after
pelosi they were like the division the
left is falling apart she
took two steps forward she fell right
back in line because she understands
that there's a lot of power that comes
from being part of something she can
criticize them
i i don't know i don't know if what
you're talking i think there are people
who can break the system right but i
firmly believe that those people come
from outside of washington dc not inside
yeah to me
i see bernie and aoc that they believe
what they're talking about bernie more
than aoc because bernie got married and
his honeymoon was in russia i mean did
you go to russia on your honeymoon i
didn't go to work he believes it but
he's not he's not living his lifestyle
doesn't ascribe to true what i mean he's
he's got a ton of money yes
and and and he had he does have a lot of
money but he's also a guy that in the
area of going up against big pharma i'm
just telling you
he will play a very important role
in beating those guys he's very very
important in that area okay
you and i don't have to agree
on hey you don't like tyler i don't like
to uh whatever kids but you like him i
don't like him whatever i like adam you
don't like adam whatever but if you and
i agree and say look that guy right
there i don't agree with that he does
this this this but that one thing
i can i can go on that one thing with
you and you open them and say look folks
bernie here and i don't agree on 99 of
things but let me tell you the one thing
that we agree on there's no way in the
world medication costs a thousand
dollars when they make it for pennies
that's the one area bernie is it fair to
say we agree on audi i say i think we
want to see that we want to see it it's
never going to happen it's never going
to happen because that's not how the
size of the political aisle i read this
book called the power of positive
thinking
you're very positive and i understand no
i i i in a in a different political
environment in a different world i hear
what you're saying it sounds great that
people would be able to focus on an
issue come together on different sides
of an aisle attack that issue
they're just it's not going to happen
because they they see it as a domino
effect and they're going in such
drastically different directions
solution wise that's the problem my
solutions are over here your solutions
are over here never to come and meet in
the center for any reason um
i just don't think it's going to happen
but we can agree to disagree on that one
i'll watch i'll i'll be i want front row
tickets and popcorn if i start bernie if
you want to talk big pharma please
you have the mic come on here let's talk
he's fine
big pharma i wouldn't be surprised if
bernie shows up one of these days okay
you talk about rogan earlier right i
want to read the story can you pull up
this tech insider article that just came
out which is absolutely uh and i'm going
to give you a prediction i'm going to
make a prediction here with this
on what i believe is going to happen
uh next
do you know which one i'm talking about
i emailed it to you if you want to pull
it up you should have it somewhere there
uh so so folks a lot of people are not
happy with this guy named joe rogan can
you do me favorite go to the actual
article instead of just having it that
way go to the actual article
it says uh put spotify misinformation
scientists
police
those words it should come up
uh uh uh uh the the the doctors call on
spotify to s okay there you go here we
go we will read this doctor's call make
it a little bit bigger so i can read it
doctors call on spotify to stop covered
misinformation citing joe rogan podcast
the platform is helping damage public
trust and scientific research according
to a letter signed by hundreds of
medical
professionals i believe the number is
270 by the way that's scientists go a
little bit higher
more than 250 medical professionals have
signed an open letter calling on spotify
to clamp down on covenant's information
spreading on his platform especially
calling out the podcast of comedian joe
rogan the letter took issue with
december 31st episode of joe rogan
experience podcast when he featured dr
robert malone an immunologist who claims
to have created the mrna technology but
is now vocal skeptic of the vaccine that
use it um
by allowing the propagation of false and
societally harmful assertions spotify is
enabling its hosted media to damage
public trust and scientific research and
sell doubt in the credibility
data-driven guidance offered by medical
professionals great words by the way the
way they awarded that sounds very legit
this is not a scientific or medical
concern it's a sociology sociological
issue of devastating pro uh proportions
and spotify islam foreign the letter was
first reported wednesday by rolling
stone okay so now watch this so now
they're attacking who they're going
after
rogan but they're really going after who
this is not right
they're going after spotify okay
so who is who who runs spotify who is
the ceo of spotify
who's the ceo spotify
pull up ceo the spotify okay and you'll
see who he is daniel eck yeah and and
what he wants to do okay
what he wants to do swedish billionaire
yeah swedish billionaire
here he's 38 years old young dude and he
wants to win
that game i think
uh of michelle obama's with them
podcasts kardashians i believe is with
them podcasts
they're going after all the big names
right where's obama
and um uh yeah i know
yeah here's all i'm saying to you
watch in the next week two weeks three
weeks four weeks if they go after this
guy because now he's a target okay watch
if something comes out with a me too uh
drug habit watch if something comes out
with his personal life you know he lost
super mario brothers when he was 18. why
something comes out right he broke up
with his first girlfriend he likes older
women he likes whatever he's into
certain kinky things something's going
to come out about this guy in the next
thing there's going to be some hit
pieces are you
think about it this way for sure who
is like that whole thing would get her
right they get her twitter and joe rogan
called him out i think he said
one of the investors and getter is what
a chinese something i don't know if you
saw that or not that he called it out so
even rogan who got them a million people
he still slammed them and it's a jurgen
slam social media platform ghetto call
it uh uh uh uh what does he call it for
uh for gazing just days after [ __ ]
yeah okay and for for gazi just days
after joining go go a little lower okay
so anyway so joe hogan calls joe rogan
calls
joe rogan calls out
um this new app because the investors in
the back end are chinese but
right now silicon valley think about how
many people like our most viewed
interview on spotify
is dr malone's interview right are most
viewed interview ever on spotify is dr
malone because everybody says where can
i get it
you can go to spotify we don't have a
rumble account rumble account ceo
reached out to me we're gonna have a
conversation see what happens there but
i'm not on rumble so point being
if this happens and they're now fearing
what rogan's doing yep if
daniel stays strong
as big as spotify's they're about to
blow up even more if he stays strong
but see this this should terrify
everyone what's going on i mean and you
know i i saw that joe rogan was a target
so i started listening to him because i
was like what is this guy doing over
there that's getting so much heat
people are terrified he's just having
people on and asking questions
he's just having guests they're coming
on doctors he's asking questions he's
not telling everyone don't get
vaccinated i have never heard him say
that he's saying look i know people who
had bad side effects i know people who
didn't what's going on here with the
data you know he taught he had a video
was released the other day that i had
missed from december where he's talking
about how pharmaceutical companies
they're the only ones that retain their
raw data this is important information
and you have
americans left right and center right
now who are tired of establishment media
because yeah you know you showed that
article and it says oh all these medical
professionals hate this
who are you talking about are you
talking about big pharma allies that are
threatened by someone who's actually
asking questions to people like malone
why are you still threatened by malone
you have a million doctors sitting on
cable news all day long that for the
last year and a half have been spouting
lies and nonsense that have then we've
watched every single one of those things
be disproven
most of them have never apologized for
anything but you can't listen to dr
malone on joe rogan give his opinion and
talk about what he sees happening why is
there a shutdown so people should be
absolutely horrified by what's happening
and you know what go and listen
go
get on joe rogan show and just listen
because the same thing happened to me
you know i was shut down for
misinformation on network television i
then wrote an article i don't know if
you know this but the daily mail had
approached me i saw that they re they
took it back or something like that they
pulled it down in the middle of the
night
the daily mail asked me to write an
article about my stand on vaccines i
wrote the article i submitted it it was
edited like i agreed to the edits they
published it in the middle of the night
it disappears with no explanation this
is happening to people in every aspect
of media
there is a shutdown of people just
asking questions
so
you know and nothing i said there i then
posted screenshots and i was like look
at what i'm saying i'm telling people to
make their own informed decision based
on their own risk benefit analysis and
their own conversations with their
doctors that's somehow threatening to
big pharma and of course it is because
big pharma is coming out with one size
fits all approaches and one size fits
all never works in medicine it never
works in health anyone who's had any
health obstacle in their life knows that
one size fits all is garbage
so
be scared you know when we were talking
about the election i remember people
talking about you know a stolen election
and i didn't buy into that because i
they were talking about voting machines
and i was having conversations i was on
fox news at the time with gop officials
on the ground who were telling me this
is not true you know we are republicans
we are making sure we are counting these
we are manually counting them after the
stuff you know is tallied up in the
machines this is not happening and i say
now if you're going to talk about an
election and collusion what you really
should have been talking about is this
stuff there was collusion going on
between big tech there was collusion
going on between politicians and big
pharma all of that was happening all of
that was happening that was what led to
the election changing the way that it
did it wasn't about covid it was about
all of that stuff it was about
manipulation of data it was about
manipulation of information it was about
cnn's tracker that was up the death
tracker and now suddenly is not there
this was all targeted so if you're a
free speech advocate i don't care i
don't give a damn if you're a republican
a democrat a libertarian if you are a
free speech advocate and you just want
people to be able to have their voices
heard to have their questions answered
then you should be appalled by what is
going on right now with the shutdown of
voices and joe rogan is an example of
that the only reason he's getting
attention is because he has a ton of
viewers and they're like oh my god this
may convince people to realize that they
should have ownership of their own lives
and their own health that's all it's
about his viewership puts uh msnbc cnn
fox news hannity tucker to shame i mean
we had the stats uploaded and i don't
agree with him on everything i mean joe
he is pat says the most necessary voice
in america right now
and so is every individual podcast and
that's people are like getting away from
corporate media and they're listening to
people like you they're listening to
people like rogan they're listening to
all of these people who are just telling
you what they think and having guests on
and asking hard questions that's all
it's about but science science is meant
to be questioned
and if you are opposing that
then then you're endorsing propaganda
you know
you know the problem with big pharma
is that there's no money in
natural immunity it can't be monetized
exactly so if there's no money in it why
the hell would they just encourage that
sure there's a lot of money in vaccines
and mass and everything there's over 140
studies now that confirm natural
immunity natural immunity is not new
this is not a new concept you know when
i went when i was pregnant and i went to
the doctor and she tested me you know
things like measles and chickenpox can
be dangerous if you get them when you're
pregnant so she said we're going to test
you we're going to test you for
antibodies even though i had been
vaccinated for measles when i was young
i had had actually had been exposed to
chickenpox i never got the rash but i
had the antibodies she tested me she
said okay you you have the antibodies
don't worry she didn't say oh you have
the antibodies let's vaccin let's give
you a booster
this is not new to scientists and
there's a lot of doctors around the
country that have been outraged not
these are doctors who are vaccinated the
guy who wrote my medical exemption is
vaccinated himself these are not
anti-vac it's not a group of
anti-vaxxers these are doctors who are
saying dr malone is vaccinated yes he's
vaccinated he thought he was going to
die he's been labeled as anti-vaccine
virtually every headline that's come out
that is absurd you know even though he
took
by the way i mean listen this is this is
this is the part that uh uh becomes a
challenge
in 2012
i lose my voice for six months i can't
talk so if you you like i can't talk at
all i'm struggling six months six months
a long time that's a long time so i'm
talking like this
that's how i'm talking six months so i'm
and i'm going on tour speaking oh my god
it's a it's a freaking very strange time
so i go to the doctor doctor's like yeah
i hate to say this you got cancer i said
what he said you got cancer he's talking
about cancer he says let me show you he
shows he says that's cancerous and it's
spreading and we got to do something
about it i'm like oh my gosh he says we
got to do surgery tomorrow i said i
can't i got to go to hawaii i got a
speech i'm giving hawaii but i can do it
on monday so no it's very important i
said i'm going to do the speech in
hawaii i'll come back and so i go to
hawaii i do the speech i come back
monday morning 5 a.m they do the surgery
but
i called two other doctors that then i
went and saw
and the other doctor says no i don't
think it's cancerous but you should do
the surgery no i don't think it's
probably going to be benign but you know
best thing is to handle it asap in case
it is cancer okay monday morning 5am we
go in
surgery's done
i wake up they take it out they call me
two three days later and i'm in colombia
out of all the places and he says hey
it's benign you're fine okay great
fantastic but the process was
after the first person told me i got
cancer i got a second opinion right when
somebody tells you what you got you get
a second opinion it's almost as if we
can no longer use that philosophy of go
get a second opinion for centuries for
decades we've been told get a second
opinion no you can't get a second
opinion can you imagine if you can't get
a second opinion on the health matter
you know i'm going to tell you who's
going to lead the charge against big
pharma it's going to be people who have
encountered a chronic condition in their
life i don't know if you know i had lyme
disease in the past um i think once you
have lyme disease you kind of always
have it lingering in your body but i got
a late stage diagnosis of that my
symptoms were crazy anyone out there
who's listening who's had lyme disease
is like i've been there i know they're
like yes
because it's it's discredited you know a
lot of a lot of pharmaceutical companies
tell you oh you have lyme disease what i
got told here take two weeks of
antibiotics you're done
i was i had
i had massive vertigo i had tingling and
numbness in my cheek at one point i was
like did i have a stroke i couldn't walk
a straight line from point a to point b
i was deathly sick muscle spasms muscle
aches chills temperature deregulation i
mean the symptoms were endless
i fixed it i didn't fix it through big
pharma because big pharma told me oh
this is the condition these are the
treatments end of story see you later if
if you still have symptoms it's just
inflammation that's what i got told i
went through holistic doctors i went
through an individualized approach i
spoke to physicians who wanted to talk
to me about what was actually happening
and i fixed it so anyone who suffered
with that and we know with this vaccine
there are a lot of groups of people who
there's no clinical trials on them
autoimmune issues this that the other
thing those people are just saying some
of them are saying i'm open to the
vaccination but just i need more data
others of them are saying my doctor is
saying he's seeing x y and z and people
like me so i'm hesitant others are
saying i had covert already i was fine
after two days i don't want to do this
because i have a proclivity toward x y
and z so in a world where there needs to
be you know you talk about empathy and
compassion with covid you should have
empathy for people who lost their lives
you should have empathy for people who
lost loved ones you can do that but at
the same time can you have some empathy
for people who don't fit inside inside
your one-size-fits-all bucket and people
who are looking at their own health and
saying this is has been advised to be
potentially hazardous for me and i'm
healthy and i'm fine so can you do you
protect yourself and let me worry about
me yeah that's scary that those people
where are where's the voice for all
those people yeah you know again so so
uh where this goes to and appreciate you
for sharing that obviously that's a
personal story but you know
this goes to one thing this is why i
trust capitalism i just trust capitalism
spotify
is ruining everything for silicon valley
is pissing these people off
spotify's making youtubers people who
watch youtube my number one app is
youtube it's my favorite app i love the
app youtube it's got a lot of potential
to change the world it's changed the
world in many ways education all these
other things but to me
spotify is i can guarantee in their
board meetings right now the name
spotify comes up regularly it comes up
in google it comes up in youtube it
comes up in facebook it comes up in
every twitter it comes up in every one
of those conversations they are all
talking about this one company in sweden
called spotify because capitalism works
i'll give you a perfect example
i go to the airport okay are you a utsa
pre are you clear are you also clear i'm
not clear because i don't fly that much
are you clear or no are you tsa or just
tsa okay so so check this out so i'm tsa
pre and i'm clear and i go to the
airport tsa pre hey yeah hey put your
mask on like i'm [ __ ] sorry
down my foot cause i forget in florida
like literally i forget every time
people have to tell me
clearer say hey do you mind putting a
mask do you need one we have a clear
mask we can give you here we go we'll
give it to you oh thank you so much okay
perfect reason why capitalism works tsa
pre public company government
organization okay
clear private company okay they have to
serve you
they have to service you or else they
don't get business
tsa pre if you tell a tsa pre-employee
what did you say i'm going to write a
negative review on yelp about tsa in
dallas good luck
i don't give a [ __ ] right tell a clear
what's your name johnny no problem i'm
going to write a negative review and i'm
going to send an email please so what
can i do to make you better i'm so sorry
this has been a terrible experience let
me make it better for you what can i do
that's capitalism capitalism is about
serving you
and the government organizations are
like you better listen to me because you
don't have an alternative okay the other
day jen we're going through
i don't know where we're going where
were we last week i don't even know
where we were anyways we're going
somewhere and jennifer's got the milk
because you know she baby's still six
months so she's still going through the
phase of uh
you know
the the all the machines that she's got
to travel with yeah but she has the milk
and she puts it through and the guy
standing there and it's been 10 minutes
i'm like got a flat so excuse me is
there any way you can how soon can you
guys take a look at jen's back wait
we'll let you know and walks off
i'm like dude i'd love to slap you
upside the head right yeah but if i do
i'm going to jail if i do that because
you can't do that right that's not
customer service let me get with you in
a minute let me see what i can let me
see if i can get somebody that's tsa so
trust capitalism and long term as long
as capitalism is this core system where
people can compete in the marketplace
product prices will go lower
products will improve websites will get
better experiences will get better
customer service will get better
customer experience in every possible
way capitalism can help make your life
better because they have to compete
think about it like these guys don't
compete is when those things don't get
better i'm listening to what you're
saying and i 100 agree but my mind
immediately goes to schools
because you have kids all around the
country suffering in schools that don't
work and every time someone suggests
vouchers every time someone suggests
charters every every time someone
suggests turning you know bringing the
free market into the educational system
and and doing something actually doing
something about that democrats come back
and say well no it's just more funding
that we need anytime we've been giving
funding to to schools for so long more
and more and more money and it doesn't
produce this was the whole thing with
betsy devos right that's exactly what
she got vilified if you watched anything
on the left you think she's the most
evil person ever she was about school
vouchers and that's essentially
capitalism
the reason you know you asked me in the
beginning if this was my hill to die on
the vaccines and i said it's not about
vaccines for me it's about freedom it's
about empowering people it's about you
have a kid and you have one school in
your district and that school is failing
and you want the opportunity to take
your child into a better school system
into a better school and you can't do
that i want to empower that family to be
able to do that i want to force those
bad schools to perform better by having
to compete with a really good school
that now kids are flocking to
and again the reason people on the left
often oppose all of these things is
because it removes power from government
and it removes power of government over
you government then can no longer tell
you what school you put your kid into
and once people realize that they don't
need government for those things that
they can rely on themselves that they
have some freedom in society they can
build their own lives that they get to
keep more of their hard-earned cash all
of those things government becomes less
and less powerful less and less needed
and the politicians that are espousing
big government
lose favor with the public so the whole
system is broken because of a lack of
freedom so i was talking education
because i came out of education in
television first now i'm talking about
vaccines i could be talking about
anything but what i'm really talking
about is freedom that is a hill i will
die on more so now because i have a
two-year-old and i'm increasingly
worried about the world that he's coming
into i want him to be a free thinker i
want him to live freely i want him to be
able to build the life he wants for
himself and make his own choices for his
own health and his own family and i want
people who are going to be an obstacle
that to be voted out of office and to
get out of his way so he has given me
a great sense of of of motivation and
power at this time and i just think of
his face and i'm like this this is worth
fighting
respect respect you for doing that
respect you for doing that a couple
things before we wrap up one uh megan
mccain okay so megan mccain uh uh she
also is no longer with them she was
going through some challenges and she
had she i think she openly talked about
the fact that she had a mental breakdown
while she was pregnant i don't know what
it was there was something she went
through that she's like man i just can't
handle this this was like i'm worried
about my the risk for my kids all these
other people all these other things
who would you say if you or megan
because megan can't stand trump like
that's the ideal person for view you
know you want somebody like that and you
called trump a third grader for calling
out chris wallace or whatever it was and
he said if obama went through it you
didn't say anything you know that whole
thing you talked about
who do you think could work for the view
is there a name or two or three that you
would say no i i think it has to be
someone that
i think they're going to wind up
probably hiring someone who hates trump
but you can't just hate trump like yeah
you know megan mccain personally she and
her family have issues with the trumps
and she's been very public about that
but i don't see her as someone who
wouldn't give credit to a policy if it
was due that's no good you have to hate
trump across the board that means
everything he does is wrong everything i
think they'll probably wind up hiring
someone who works for a cnn or you know
a a company that you know liberals like
to see conservatives oh well they're
legit they work for cnn so there's one
name that came to mind that's on cnn
that's exactly who i thought of that's
the girl with the initials
not anna navarro
as he comes so i know essie yeah um
pretty well it's possible i think you
she's a conservative but she's on cnn
and
i think she's definitely not a
traditional liberal at all
they're going to they're going to know
her with the glasses
they're going to find someone who agrees
with them most of the time disagrees
politely
and on the key issues remember there are
key issues that
liberals prioritize okay so there's key
right you know trump
the uh j what happened on january 6
right now these are hot issues um
there's issues about race that you can't
ask questions you know critical race
theory or you the they're
the conservative they pick and i say
that in quotation marks has to fall in
line on those key issues
they can talk about low taxes they can
quietly disagree that maybe kamala
harris isn't a great candidate but it
has to be in a way that doesn't disrupt
the narrative it has to be a way that if
there are these key issues
that they're preserved and that the
audience walks away feeling like oh this
is the right okay well they deserve this
is the right way of seeing things
anything that threatens that is going to
be a problem but yeah this goes back to
my initial question this is sort of
essentially what pat was basically
describing with the you know the the
socialist democrats and basically the
tea party movement why does it have to
be one unicorn person that hates you
like why can't you have a maga person a
rhino a uh i'll tell you a liz cheney
and then have a couple like why have to
if they're because of that in one person
because it's terrifying that the
audience would walk away and actually be
thinking
when i left when i left the view i will
tell you i got
so many messages from people who said
i disagree with you but you made me
think
i disagree with you but you changed my
perception about what a conservative is
i disagree with you but i don't know
maybe i think about this this and this a
little bit differently now that is
terrifying to a liberal establishment
old-school network that has a goal there
is an agenda you don't see anything
clearly too you realize there is an
agenda here what's the idea and the
agenda is to have someone on there that
you can claim a diversity of thought
label on but actually not prevent
present diversity of thought to the
audience
so it's a claim and you know it's a
facade it's a facade 100
um and if you do get somebody on there
like me i think megan you know stood
firm on conservative principles in many
ways i think that it presents a problem
it proves that sometimes it presents
behind the scenes problem that was not
the case with me seems to be that that
was the case with her that she was
sensing from what about abby huntsman
abby's very neutral abby and i have been
in similar jobs i don't know if you know
abby hosted fox and friends weekend
before i did but abby's very
um
she's she's kind of neutral she wants to
see both sides her brand is very much
like let's come together what's wrong
with that though
i don't see not enough fireworks right
see the challenge is you want fireworks
but you almost want somebody like i
think their ideal candidate would be
somebody that created fireworks but the
audience didn't like didn't or did like
didn't they didn't like because they're
an unconvincing man
they're unconvincing you need to be
unconvincing
yes because if you're convincing
conservative you have compelled people
to think let me tell you i have one you
know what the hell that means well i
have a name that if if this person was
on there i think it'd be like the
top show competing with everybody
if kellyanne conway
that would be fun she's been on there
before yeah but i'm talking about i'm
talking about if kellyanne conway came
out and said yeah she signed a one-year
contract to be on the view it'd be
fireworks because it'd be so
uncomfortable for that i can just
imagine joey's face
how disturbing it would be but that to
me is television that's she's not
interested maybe kelly and conaway's
daughter would be but if she would you
see what's going on with those she would
you see that i do i do she would be very
supportive and another person by the way
recently apparently ted cruz's uh yeah
it was at one of his kids
yeah and and also not
it supported
also not supportive what about ted
cruz's ugly wife
you're saying that because of what trump
said yeah exactly yeah you know i'm just
making that clear clearing that down for
you i think everyone knows yeah and that
goes to show you too hey ted your wife's
ugly and your dad killed jfk
do i have your vote yes sir mr trump
thank you all right ted cruz lost a lot
of support after that because they were
like what who are you what do you stand
for exactly so sure of course that's
politicians though again i always tell
people don't pledge allegiance to
politicians they will disappoint you
if there's anything that i took from
this was a lot and i think obviously
she's awesome is not the allegiance to
any political party or any any political
that's right person just do you and you
can you can agree and disagree and uh
it's an issue thing what a lady we got
right what a lady we got well i hope you
guys have had fun yes this is fun this
was great so tell us tell us about uh
billa.locals.com yeah so i got tired of
social media censorship you see what's
been happening on twitter in particular
people are getting banned malone was
banned everyone's getting banned for
this and that i've had numerous friends
that have just been reporting facts that
get banned then of course when the cdc
comes out and supports it we're like oh
is that not misinformation what's going
on here so there's a place called locals
that i you know i spoke to their reps
over there and i said you know what i
want to create a censorship free zone
where i can talk to people where i can
share information where they can share
information with me where i don't have
to worry that you know big brother
silicon valley is looking over my
shoulder with their agenda-driven
nonsense so it's just a free free
exchange of ideas it's something that
should be happening in a free society
everywhere i invite people to ask
questions i'm going to be giving behind
the scenes look at some projects that
are coming up there i'm going to
probably post a clip from us talking
today over there if you guys give me one
and it's just a space where people feel
like they can be free thinking people
and it's a conversation it's what you
know social media promised and didn't
deliver so it's beela.locals.com um
there's going to be some family stuff
it's not all politics it's going to be
you know culture media it's going to be
family it's going to be value based some
stuff about my book dear hartley and
what i hope for the next generation but
more than that it's just going to be a
space where people feel like they can be
themselves and they can ask things and
i'm not going to criminalize them for
asking a question you know what's going
on bad
name or rep these days is the
the word free thinkers right like the
word free thinker has now been hijacked
like oh you're a free thinker
i don't know about this guy he's
thinking
it's very different very weird right
what's the opposite of free thinking
though
boxed in i don't know what what's the
what's the word you got in mind i'm i'm
asking you you speak english better than
i do that i'm someone i'm the loyalist
it's a loyalist they're a loyalist
is that blind thinking blind thinkers
listen it happens on the right too it
happens on the right too there's people
on the right 4744 i've taken heat at abc
i've taken heat you know fox news i've
taken heat for just being someone who
isn't willing to tow a line and there's
you know what the thing is that's
frustrating is what i'm doing is
reflective of the average person out
there people don't just have those
loyalties they ask questions they sit
around the dinner table they agree they
disagree they're not living in that dc
bubble of that media elite that's they
care about if you only watch the media
you think americans hate each other i
mean look at this office right here
we've got
left right center gay straight brown
black white like wait everyone gets
along there's another guy on the podcast
gerard shout out to him people think
we're freaking enemies we don't have
lunch yesterday like we hang out we're
buddies it's not
that serious but the media basically
portrays its left it's trying to trump
and spider and pick a side wrestling
match too you know pay-per-view aoc
candace owens let's fight it out i'd
like to see that by the way that would
be fascinating you might even want to be
uh coming off the top rope maybe i could
can i moderate that i'll moderate i
don't feel like you're going to be
moderate at all i feel like you're just
i can moderate it like coming in with
the people's elbows that's true i'll
have elbow pads on hopefully
but um this was a blast thank you
patrick for this free exchange of ideas
yeah really enjoyed it and i know your
next move is between uh texas and
florida
uh uh uh florida long if you're like
lifestyle if you like no taxes here's
the pitch
a low
regulation with a governor that could
potentially end up being the president
of the united states
and you are eight hours away from europe
if you want to go on vacation you're an
hour away from all the caribbean all the
baha all that stuff you're 45 minutes to
from cuba if you want to go to cuba he
loves cuba if you want to go down to
south beach i know a couple places that
we can yeah so your husband will like it
you've got a great tan do you like bing
tan or you like being pale i don't even
really have a tan i'm italian though so
i could exactly do do you like to say do
you like the beach i like my vitamin d i
like my vitamin d
taxes might not be for you i don't know
gonna have to feel it out either way i
will be leaving the bad dystopian novel
that is new york city and either either
texas or florida will be a vast
improvement let me ask you one question
about new york city before we go i asked
this to a lot of new yorkers i don't
know if you've heard they're moving down
here in droves oh i've heard um
i say you know scale of one to ten ten
being new york city at its full go
system energy everything's amazing
one being like just full lockdown
shutdown where is new york city right
now as of january of 2022
it's at like a it's
it's not like a four but it's it's it's
open
but but people have left and everyone's
walking around looking hypnotized like a
stafford wife like that that mass
formation psychosis is real
go to you know what you think it's made
up do me a favor go to manhattan for a
weekend and then come tell me what you
think you have to go every summer for a
month and i'm saying this as someone who
grew up in new york who had great
experiences in new york who wants new
york to come back who loves the the the
way new york used to be it was
rebellious it was edgy it questioned
authority it was cool it's none of those
things they're hypnotized people are
hypnotized and they are government
loyalists at this point and they're and
they're living in fear in horrible
crippling fear how are they going to get
out of that they're going to get out of
it when the city sinks goes underwater
and then they finally realize that the
stuff they've been voting for is the
reason that it sinks and they start
voting differently if that doesn't
happen it's going to stay underwater
damn jedediah you're the bomb stadium
listen next time i come in here i expect
the money to be no we'll have it we'll
have a stack for you right in front
we'll have that
and she's all over twitter and very
active send her tweet
and she will generally respond i see how
active she is on twitter